Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
[inaudible]
yeah.
How are you?
How's your week going?
Ah,
back to the grind.
Back to the fucking grind.
You too.
Oh yeah.
How was,
how was your,
how was your time off?
Do you have a nice holiday?
Did Ya,
did Ya dead yet?
Oh yeah.
How old is she now?
Really?
Can I check off door yet?
Just kidding.
I'll see it break.
All right.
Oh,
you haven't those fucking conversations.
the holidays are over and it's back to the grind.
Sitting in traffic though,
into your cubicle.
I think I'm going to kill my boss if I don't drive into the wall.
Um,
I actually had a fucking panic attack.
Not a semi panic attack.
Sorta like I fucking nose dives into a bit of a depression yesterday.
Just stick another fucking year.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
Here we fucking go again.
Uh,
we have a mechanical problem with the aircraft.
We're just going to pull over here on the tarmac.
We have a landing light that is inoperable at this moment.
We're gonna sit tight here and wait to learn the mechanics come out here,
which I do not have a estimated time on at this point,
but a well,
we deal.
Guess what information will lack.
In fact,
his Sudeley cat had died till that.
Now it's getting me apologize for the delay at,
uh,
just try and sit back and relax,
especially Canada.
I've got to try to keep the air on.
Uh,
apologize if it gets a little hot back there.
Now the fucking year of that,
another fucking year of that.
The show's a great,
it's the getting the,
getting to the shows.
Um,
oh God.
People taking their fucking shoes.
I look,
if you take your shoes off and you have socks on,
I fucking get it.
All right.
Just don't rub your feet together.
I've talked about it before.
My just can you not rub your fucking feet together?
Foot,
foot,
foot.
It fucking drives me nuts that just,
uh,
just want to punch the back of the fucking chair.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
what is going on with me?
I'm going to be on the cow,
Colin cowherd show,
uh,
today.
Hyping a F is for family.
I'm going into Netflix today and we're going to do our little song and dance and
pitch them our season arc for a season two.
Basically.
Uh,
that's what you do after you do the first one.
And they go,
hey,
Yo were pretty good.
Pretty good,
but now where are you going to go?
Well,
you're going to go with it now and then you got to get in the eye.
He had a dead,
a dead I would to do to do to,
he does this.
She does that.
Give it some more fucking money please.
Then they go,
oh,
we'll think about it then.
Yeah.
Everybody walks.
Outcome.
I think there were good.
You think we're good?
I think it
went good.
I don't know here.
What should we here Tuesday,
Wednesday at the latest?
Uh,
we don't think every bloody for Ra flat a frameless gas here the day.
Yeah.
Fortunately you were at dealing with little bit of weather in the Dallas Fort
Worth area.
Uh,
who number 72 in line?
Um,
unfortunately it's really nothing we could do here.
Be patient,
we can try and make up some table or in the air you gonna Trust Loulou faster,
poured a little more fuel,
we can try and put her own hole in the ozone layer.
You know what I'm saying?
Now the year that,
but you know what else?
You know sometimes,
you know,
I don't know.
Every once in a while I just fucking drive down the street.
I just see a homeless guy laying on the sidewalk sleeping,
you know?
And as much as uncomfortable as is,
you just look and just like,
you know,
I would fucking love to do that right now.
Just pull over and laid down on the ground and take a fucking nap.
Now I don't want to live outside.
Okay.
And granted,
I know that that homeless guy is sleeping during the day because at night that's
when the people come up out of the sewer drains,
like in fucking,
uh,
escape from New York,
you know,
cause they have to feed.
So when you're homeless,
she got to be up at night,
you know,
a lot of pill.
It is Bob taking a nap in the middle of the fucking afternoon.
That's because it night,
right?
These have been like a fucking,
you know,
a two by four fight fighting off.
All right.
He's dealing with that shit.
So,
uh,
but I like the nap part of it.
I'm actually looking at the homeless guy's life,
the way a woman looks at a man's life.
Like,
that looks fun.
I want to do that.
I don't want to pay the price for it,
but I'd like that.
And my
equal rights,
I am in a fucking mood.
Um,
all right.
I go on Facebook because I'm an old white guy.
I love,
I love the Facebook.
I absolutely love it.
I don't give a fuck.
Even if I delete my account,
they never deleted cause or that creepy cunt who I judged by the actor who
played him.
I don't even know what the real Zuckerberg looks like.
Is that his name?
Oh,
I fucked up the other day.
I said Lamar London instead of Lamar Hunt.
He was the original owner of the,
of the,
uh,
Dallas,
Texas.
Lamar Lundy was part of the fearsome foursome.
And what's funny is that's the fucking name I can never remember.
You know,
when they go name the first and force them,
I'm always like,
oh,
hi Rosie Greer,
Merlin Ocean,
uh,
Deca Joe.
Yeah.
And
yeah,
Lamar Lundy's like the bass player and a huge bad,
right?
You can never the bass player,
you know,
unless they're really,
if they're,
unless they're like one of those front man bass players like Steve Harris,
you know,
Billy sheen and you know,
back in the day,
John and twist,
you know,
or they play in a trio because then you only have to remember three names.
But if they play in a band of four or more people,
you just can never remember the bass player's name.
You know,
Lamar Lundy.
Is that all right?
What's switch the front floor for the Steelers?
I don't think I can name that was me.
Joe Greene,
LC,
Greenwood.
Dwight White,
Eh,
uh,
and the bass player.
What the fuck was his name?
It's a great name too.
Uh,
it's a fucking shame.
I'm,
I'm gonna have to look that up.
I have to look that up.
Like,
he can't disrespect the fucking 70 Steelers.
They went forward.
Oh,
and titles.
You can't,
you can't disrespect the team.
You know who's fan base?
I'm not going to get into it area right.
Here we go.
Okay.
Steelers front for,
there's a bunch of people in fucking,
uh,
is a bunch of people in Pittsburgh right now screaming at their fucking
the steel curtain.
Who,
where are they?
The steel curtain,
Yada,
Yada.
Me.
Joe Greene,
LC already fucking homes.
What a great name.
Ernie Holmes.
Hmm.
Just coming down tonight already homes.
You know,
he's going to be at least six,
five.
Anyways,
they're going to be man's name's left anymore.
Do they?
This is coming from a guy named bill.
Won't you will come home.
Bill Bailey.
Um,
go back here.
What did I want?
Oh,
here's what I wanted to talk about.
The uh,
the Los Angeles Rams.
They,
the Saint Louis Rams.
Yeah.
Slash Los Angeles Rams.
Slash Cleveland brands.
Hi.
Slash Cleveland Rams.
They comment back there.
Gum it back.
I'm so psyched that they're coming back.
I'm so psyched that it was the rams and not the chargers or the Raiders there.
A's.
I'm so fucking excited.
Okay.
La does not need the chargers or hey,
we don't need him to stay away.
Okay.
La needs the rams,
blue and yellow.
The Rams,
the Los Angeles Rams.
That's what they need.
They don't need,
they don't need the fucking,
they don't need to bring the Raiders.
But if you bring the Raiders back,
the city of Los Angeles,
if you bring the Raiders back,
you're basically signing off on the fact that someone's going to get stabbed or
shot.
It's just,
it's a fact.
Just watch the 30 for 30 on the fucking Los Angeles Rams,
the one that ice cube,
uh,
narrates the way he's talking and all that shit.
It's fucking,
it's actually inadvertently like hilarious.
It's just the level of like,
La doesn't eat.
You don't,
you don't fucking need it.
Somebody is going to like,
they can't handle,
they can't handle those colors.
They can't handle the pirate on the side of the,
keep it in fucking Oakland where people just dress up.
Like it's going to be a musical.
And even then somebody got shot at a fucking 40 niners Raiders,
like a pregame thank you.
You,
you don't need it.
You know,
it's funny,
everybody always talks about the Philly fans and how east coast fans.
Oh,
Yankees,
red sox.
It's nothing compared to out here.
People die out here.
Guy went to a fucking Dodger's game with this kid and had on a giants Jersey and
he had,
he has brain damage for the rest of his fucking life because this fucking two,
two guys jumped up while his kid sat there and watched.
That was at a fucking baseball game.
The rams.
That's it.
Hi.
Where are the rams?
Perfect.
Okay.
You don't need the autumn wind was Erie.
You don't need to bring that to the inland empire.
They don't need to do that.
I'm telling you.
And I'm basing charger fans on the one fucking charger game that I fucking went
to add.
Um,
I,
oh,
you know,
me and La head almost got into a fight when we were there and I was rooting for
the chargers.
I just had a patriots hat on.
It was an old school patriots had,
it was all fucking beat up.
They will play in the fucking colts.
I'm cheering the charges.
That alone.
I mean I expected to get a little bit of shit right,
a little bit of Shit,
but to get to the point that it's going to be a physical confrontation and
somebody dumps a beer on you and that type of shit.
All my bad,
but they did it on purpose.
Like,
yeah,
fuck that.
Keep those fucking animals where they're at.
Keep them where they're at.
Like just,
you know,
keep the rocky horror picture show in the end zone.
Keep that up and fucking Oakland.
Plus it's the Oakland Raiders.
That's their fucking say.
I'm kind of giving the I inadvertently given Oakland's shit.
I don't mean to do that.
It's the Oakland Raiders.
All right.
They came down here before they tried to make it in Hollywood.
They couldn't,
you know,
they got a couple of guest stars on the fall guy,
you know.
Then they did an episode of full House and then it just sort of dried up for him
and then they put their tail between their legs.
They went back home,
they took over their dad's business.
I don't understand why they coming back
and why everybody all at once.
All of a sudden everybody wants to come here.
We've been sitting here for 20 fucking years without a team.
Now all of a sudden everybody wants to come back.
The Ram should come back there.
Los Angeles team,
all right.
Now I know the charges started here in la,
like their first or first year or two on the AFL,
but uh,
yeah,
keep it down in San Diego,
you know,
and said,
hey,
you don't understand my standing with San Diego's a great place.
It's one of them met most mellow,
great places.
When you go down there,
you like,
this is everything that Ellis should be.
It's chill,
it's fucking relaxed.
You've got the weather.
This is great.
It's not the grind of La.
That's what San Diego feels like when I go down there.
Fucking love it.
But then for whatever fucking reason,
you go to a sporting event and these people turn into fucking maniacs,
not a padre games just to charger games.
They just,
if fucking animals.
Um,
I dunno.
Maybe if they built them a nicer stadium and then they gave him a mascot.
I have no idea.
But I do think it's really fucked up that,
you know,
the Raiders are going to leave because you know,
in the charges are going to leave and Saint Louis is leaving basically.
Cause they don't like their stadiums and they're throwing a fucking temper
tantrum.
It's the NFL is so fucked up,
man was sports in general that they do that to people.
It's like,
dude,
it's your league.
It's your fucking business.
You know what I mean?
You don't like you fucking place of work,
you know,
build another one.
I don't know,
there's that,
but there's no way to organize people to get them just to,
to stand up to owners.
Right.
Like I remember hearing when I was working in Indianapolis in Indianapolis,
you know,
they played at the,
I was at the Hoosier dome or whatever.
Um,
when they were building that Lucas oil field,
this taxi driver when I was there was telling me that,
that the city will,
they weren't even done paying off the RCA dome or whatever the fuck they called
it.
They weren't even done paying that off.
And then they had this fucking thing.
If you've never been to Indianapolis,
I don't know if,
uh,
the,
the Hoosier dome,
Rca Dome,
whatever the fuck it was called,
if that's still standing,
but when they've,
we'll fucking building Lucas oil field and it was right next to the,
uh,
the old one,
which I believe is torn down.
You could fit like two of those inside the new one and stack two on top of each
other.
Um,
the size of this fucking new one.
I only can only imagine how much tax payers have to pay for that shit.
And it's fucking stupid.
The whole thing's fucking stupid.
I,
I really believe that once you make a stadium that should be a stadium and he
just keep fixing the fucking thing up the way I'm fixing up my shed hall of Aha.
Sorry,
I just discovered something else that was fucked up with my house.
But you know what,
right now,
the stubborn German Irish guy in me,
I'm just like,
you know what,
bring it up.
Sync every fucking dime I have into this goddamn
taken on water.
Shit.
Hole of a boat.
I'm,
I'm done.
I'm fucking done.
Like,
uh,
I'm having somebody come over today to look at my garage.
And uh,
somebody built off of,
uh,
my office here,
they built this closet and they extended this room itself.
And uh,
I don't know who's friend of a friend built this fucking thing,
but it literally sits,
uh,
right above my garage and on these two wooden,
like,
I don't even know what the terminology is there.
Not Two by fours was a four by sixes,
whatever.
It's wood and it's always bothered me.
And then down,
I talked about this in the last podcast,
but beneath that is my garage.
And in my garage right underneath that wood is a steel beam that goes across the
garage,
does a steel beam going down one side and not on the other cause there's a
window there.
So they said,
well,
forget supporting the entire fucking structure.
Let's put a window here so I can look at my neighbor's house that's fucking six
inches away.
Okay.
Yeah.
One of the first things I did when I bought the houses,
I put a shade up and pulled it down and I've never brought it back up again
until the other day when the guy looked.
Um,
so anyways,
I think when you get like a stadium,
like just,
just fix the fucking thing up.
Okay.
Just fix it up and keep fixing the fucking thing up.
And that's it.
Okay.
What do you do if you ever,
ever gotten tickets into a luxury box?
It sucks.
The food socks.
You're 9 million miles away from the game.
You now the upper deck is further away from the game.
It fucking blows.
I wish you guys,
you,
you young people out there.
I wish back in the day you could've gone to like,
uh,
like the Boston Garden.
Maple Leaf Garden.
Um,
okay.
I mean,
I never went to a game there.
I took a tour of the place,
but I,
I'll just go with the ones that I went to,
the old fucking Boston Garden.
Dude,
you are on top of the fucking game.
Okay.
It was like thunder dome when you were,
you were in the upper deck of those fucking stadium stood it.
You literally felt like if you lean too far forward,
you can have fall down and you would hit the ice.
That's how steep it was.
But now they're like the fire code and you know,
to get the fucking elephants out,
you know,
it's got to be fucking more chill,
of relaxed grade.
I don't know.
I'm not into it,
but I'm psyched at the rams are back.
I feel like the ram should be there.
I feel like San Diego should be in San Diego.
I feel like Oakland should be an Oakland,
you know,
like the way it was when I was a kid.
Um,
and that's it.
And I know I was kind of fucking rough on fucking la fans,
but it's true.
Anaheim,
I went down to Anaheim one time,
we would share it on the red sox.
We had on our red sock shit,
you know,
but we weren't conscious about it.
I used to wear red shocks,
suck stuff into a Yankee Stadium and people would break my balls,
chance some shit and point at me when I laughed it off and they saw that I was a
good shit or whatever.
And then they would,
then they would do that anyway.
How long are you down here in New York?
I lived down here,
I really blah blah,
blah,
you know,
and then they'd score and they'd fucking laugh at me and give me shit or
whatever and know and if we scored and won the game,
I wouldn't fucking point Adam and stuff.
I wasn't,
uh,
I wasn't a dick.
All right.
Cause this is my thing.
If you go into a stadium with the other jersey,
you got to expect to get some shit.
All right.
But like once you demonstrate that you're not going to be a fucking obnoxious
ask.
People should leave you alone.
You know what I mean?
You're just making a road trip.
You're showing the other stadium respect that you wanted to come.
And see it and that should be the fucking end of it.
And that was my experience when I was living in New York.
I came out here and it's just like,
no,
I'm going to stab you in the fucking neck.
So,
well actually,
you know,
I'm always bitching about the population prompts.
You know what,
fuck all that.
Fuck the last 18 minutes of this podcast,
bring their a,
it's bring them down here.
Maybe some people will fucking die.
It'll be a couple less people procreating,
you know,
Bill,
did you really have to take it today?
Yeah,
I think I did.
Um,
all right.
You know what that kind of reminds me of though is the,
uh,
these fucking people who are baiting Trump supporters.
Now I'm not,
I'm not going to get into politics here,
but you know,
you got to call a spade a spade here.
I mean that those people are mouth breathing morons.
Uh,
and Trump is up there not saying anything and getting them to go absolutely
fucking nuts.
Uh,
and it's actually a,
it's like watching a movie where they're kind of warning you about,
I dunno,
when I watched Trump,
when I listened to what he says,
it,
it reminds me of like some couple of Hollywood movies that I've seen
and the person running for office.
It's just so over the top and ridiculous.
It just reminds you that you're watching a movie and just like,
why did they go that far?
If they just fucking dialed it back a little bit,
I,
this could be a little more believable and a,
you'd have a much better,
much better movie.
And then along came Trump and,
uh,
you know,
I owe all of those,
uh,
movies and apology,
but I do have to say this,
the fucking nerds who went to the,
one of the latest Trump rallies and had a sign,
Obama's a good president.
This country already is great,
but they,
you just went in there,
you know,
you went in there to pick a fight and then they videotaped it.
And when they tore up your signs,
what's,
you knew they weren't going to do?
You get to be like Trump supporters.
His hit a new low,
I guess the reason why they're doing that right now,
which is really what that is,
is basically entrapment.
That's like they throw drugs at your feet.
Oh,
what's that?
Um,
no,
that's actually not so well what if like some smoking hot chick,
he just walk up to some fatty and she's just like,
Hey,
you want me to suck your Dick?
Give me 20 bucks.
And he's like,
okay,
let me finish this muffin and the cops just come in.
You can't fucking do that.
You can't tempt,
he can't tempt somebody like that.
And I feel like that's kind of what they did with them.
But um,
having said all that,
yeah.
Um,
that thinks stopped being funny,
like a good four to six months ago and it's just like,
wait a minute,
is this guy going to get the nomination?
You know,
all are begging for is just give me two reasonable human beings to sane,
reasonable human beings.
You know what I mean?
That,
that,
you know,
on either fucking side.
And they gave me that third fucking option.
Just be fucking reasonable.
Then walk around.
I'm going to bomb the shit out of.
So it's,
the fuck is wrong with you.
It's always the guys who don't have to go over there and do well.
You know,
I'm fucking,
I'm the tough guy behind the fucking desk.
Um,
I don't know.
I can't believe nobody slept that wig off yet,
you know?
Um,
all right,
let's,
uh,
let's plow ahead.
As somebody who's trying to keep up with both hockey and basketball,
this is what ends up happening.
You just end up watching your own teams and you don't know what the rest of the
League is doing.
And that's what's going on with me because I used to check in with the Dallas
Stars and uh,
and the,
uh,
the Black Hawks and the,
um,
and the La Kings,
just teams I really like watching and I haven't had a chance to,
so I've just been watching the Bruins fucking lose,
lose,
lose on this road trip.
We lost a jersey,
then we lost to a
fuck.
Did we lose?
No,
he beat Jersey,
right?
We beat Jersey and we've lost three in a row.
We lost to the flyers,
the rages and Ottawa.
I will say auto was the,
was the most enjoyable loss because it's my belief that the best thing in sports
right now is three on three overtime hockey.
Even if you fucking everybody who bitches about hockey,
this is the hockey.
You want to see no fights racing up and down the ice and someone's can basically
going to score within five fucking minutes.
You'll love it.
Um,
I don't know if there's any youtube videos you could watch the whole fucking
overtime.
They,
the Ottawa Bruins over time it was,
it was,
we lost and I was,
I almost stood up and applauded.
It was that fucking enjoyable to see.
Um,
was incredible.
Yeah.
It's almost like when you watch it,
you're like,
you know what?
Maybe there's too many people playing professional hockey.
I want to take anybody's job.
But if it was three on three from the get go of Jesus Christ,
the whole fucking game,
you know what,
what happened?
Somebody would die it to cardio would just be off the fucking,
has anybody interviewed a Nhl player yet to say like,
what is it like,
what's it like to,
to,
um,
to take a shift or in like three on three overtime versus when it's a five on
five,
not including the goaltenders.
Okay.
For all you fucking number nerds out there.
Like what is that like?
Are you more winded?
Is there an unbelievable freedom?
Because you don't have to worry about getting checked.
It's got to be fucking incredible feeling like you're playing pond hockey.
Um,
anyways.
And then the fucking Celtics,
they finally,
one last night,
of course I missed the Goddamn game.
I just them to fucking lost to the Knicks do that Porzingis guy.
Holy Fuck.
He's like a 10 foot Larry Bird.
He was looking like that in the first quarter.
Guy was just hitting one,
three after another and then he,
he took one shot,
three point shot.
This guy,
it's like seven foot two or three or something.
He took a three pointer from like,
fuck it looked like he was like eight feet behind the Ark and they just want
wash.
And what's funny is it's each three daddy hit the fucking noises that the crowd
was making.
Like basically this is the guy,
I think this is the guy.
Like he'd hit one,
they like,
they cheer,
but you hear it like underneath the chair here.
Oh.
Then he hits a second.
Then the third one I like freaking the fuck out
and you can tell a mellow loves fucking play with them.
They're past,
knew each other.
It was fucking great.
So I'm sitting there watching it going like,
all right,
if we're going to lose these guys,
at least I get to watch,
you know,
the oldest star having fun with the new kid.
Um,
you know,
it was,
it was just really fun to watch the two of them playing and uh,
Jesus Christ,
God help the League if they get a fucking point guard,
Huh?
Well I'm not the whole league,
but I mean they could fuck with the Cavaliers,
couldn't they?
Maybe.
I don't know shit about hoop.
I'm going to shut up.
But I enjoyed watching them play and everything's going great.
And I got it.
So you know what?
I'm going to watch the rest of this fucking game.
And who knows?
Maybe I'll watch one of these guys put up 40.
Right?
Who knows?
And uh,
and then I'll send it all went to shit.
Mallows backing up the fucking court,
the ref standing there,
he steps on the refs 40 turns his fucking ankle and then that's it.
It's fucking it.
He tried coming back out after the half and then he just said,
fuck it left.
I'm out.
I dropped my fucking 20 for the evening.
I'll see you.
And he fucking leaves.
I saw the other night,
he's still not fucking playing because he stepped on the refs foot,
so he keeps fucking leaves.
So I'm like,
all right,
let's see if the kid can lead the team era.
And then next thing you know,
he's got like five fucking files and he's sitting down.
And this is funny.
That's funny thing is we still lost the Goddamn game.
I actually love the Celtics.
They're young and everything,
but they,
uh,
they love scoring like 35 and the first quarter,
you know,
and going up by 10,
12,
19,
I watched him lose to Memphis to having a 19 point fucking lead and uh,
I dunno,
I still like them and to think it just fucking hang onto a goddamn lead.
I could enjoy it a little bit more,
but by the way,
so last night they were playing the paces and um,
one of the fuck most fucked up things ever.
I was sitting there looking at the pacers wearing these uniforms and I'm like,
where do I know those uniforms from?
And it looked it up online.
They were wearing the uniforms,
the same uniforms that they wear in that movie.
Hoosiers,
right.
Am I correct in assuming that?
Let me look this up before I make fun of them for actually doing that.
Okay.
Hoosiers movie.
Images.
It's all going to be gene Hackman's face,
right?
Yeah.
They were wearing those things.
Do you really sell fucked up?
That is,
hey black guys,
why don't you put on these uniforms that white people used to wear when you
weren't allowed to play?
Second,
Sean,
I want to say of away and those are fucking what was fucking a white why verse
yt they all White Days,
right?
Look at the pictures.
A picture of the fucking team in black and white that they were doing.
All right.
Number 43 white number 15 white number 53 white,
25 white,
13 wide,
12 white,
14 white.
The other guy can read his number
are all white.
Why?
Why would you have them?
Where those,
what did,
what are you going to have the uh,
the color barrier?
Broken uniforms one day this year.
I don't know.
It seemed like an odd fucking choice to me.
However,
Indiana has such a weird fucking ah,
it's such a weird fucking state.
You know,
it's really just like a,
you know,
just odd golly gee shucks white people slash
astoundingly racist.
You know,
like as much shit as Boston.
Like the only places that get shit for being racist.
Basically.
It's the south and Boston,
Massachusetts and not having been on the road.
I don't know if I'll,
how fucking long as she can
we,
yeah,
no,
there's no worse is when the,
uh,
when you're still at the gate and they're just like
touching everybody on American Airlines flight one,
nine or seven,
six to Albuquerque.
Um,
we're still waiting for our flight crew to show up.
So it's probably going to be another 40 minutes if you'd like to get something
to eat,
but don't want it too far.
That's shit.
I don't even know why I just went into that.
Um,
I don't even fucking remember.
You know what?
And I've,
I've been,
I've been doing this long enough to just say fuck that idea and I'm just going
to continue one.
All right.
So we got a patriots versus the chiefs this weekend in playoffs,
football playoffs.
Um,
and I think that,
uh,
we could possibly win that game by the skin of our teeth.
It all depends on who comes back.
Uh,
but if we do not have an offensive line,
then uh,
our,
our goose is cooked because our starting running back,
who I can't even remember his fucking name,
he's been out for so long.
I,
you know,
I really need to just pick a sport.
You can't fucking watch him off.
That's what I'm trying to do.
And watching the Patriots,
Bruins and Celtics,
and I don't even know anybody's fucking name,
any mice to know the fucking lines or the Bruins.
I don't even know.
I'm just sitting there.
You know what it is it,
this is my fucking,
I dunno what the,
that the psychological term is.
It's like,
oh,
I'm going to,
I'm going to get them,
I don't know,
watch the Bruins much.
All the Bruins Games,
watch all the Bruins games and then first he comes out,
I'll get the basketball watch off.
Rose.
I'm just fucking sitting here binge watching this shit like a maniac.
I think I need to step back for a second and get my priorities in order and
realize that the Patriots are in the fucking playoffs and the Bruins and Celtics
is still in the regular season.
I just be paying attention to the Patriots.
Right,
right.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I think,
uh,
see,
I think it's Seattle.
I think Seattle,
they had their fucking little,
you know,
when you win a game the way Seattle one last week,
which is basically the other team basically screws to poach.
You got to start to feel like,
yeah,
you're kind of a team of destiny.
Right.
And I know one year the Patriots,
you know,
the ravens missed to field goal and that got us into a Superbowl.
But uh,
that one made me feel like we backed in,
but like I really think like Seattle,
if it wasn't fucking nine degrees out or 10 below zero,
I thought that was really in the vikings favor kind of slowed them down a little
bit,
evened out the field.
And I can say that knowing nothing about the vikings,
I'm going to shut the fuck up right now.
How about that?
Would that be all right?
Um,
anyways,
well that's the half hour here.
I got to,
uh,
I gotta go fucking,
put on my monkey suit here.
It makes sure that I look like I'm from Indiana when I go in to go pitch the
second season here.
So anyways,
thank you everybody for listening to the,
uh,
Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in on you,
uh,
episode.
Uh,
now we're going to do a little throwback shit.
Um,
I didn't see any advertising for this week.
maybe you listen to some advertising right now that it recorded on my phone on
the way to the fucking meeting.
I have no fucking idea what you're going to hear right now,
but I know eventually you're going to hear some throwback shit from a podcast
from a year gone by.
All right,
have a great weekend.
You cuts.
Okay.
Shit.
I gotta read five of these fucking things.
The advertisements here,
this is not the throwback part.
This is the advertising part.
I guess I missed two of them on Monday.
So here we go.
Am v M t watches everybody.
Movement.
Watches was started by two college dropouts were flunkies man with the idea to
make quality watches that don't break the bank.
Starting at 95 bucks and sold online,
they cut out all the bullshit retail markup,
supposedly movement sent some watches over here.
Question Mark.
I guess that wasn't supposed to read that.
Yeah,
they did.
They write they,
I got them.
They're great.
I'm not lying.
I have in my closet.
I'm not wearing them,
you know,
but I liked him.
Quality material and sleek design.
The perfect every day.
Watch it's easy.
Order online today for free shipping.
Free returns in a 24 month warranty.
Join the movement and say no big hand retail markups and saying yes to great
style.
Checkout MVMT watches.com/burr and you'll get 50 15% off your entire purchase.
That's M v M t watches.com/berg.
What's up Cleo?
All right.
Oh Shit.
Here we go.
Ah,
Biondi he's having a nice fucking drag tank,
but who do to me?
Andy's me.
Andy is no more reason to paint.
You fought being balls because they're nice and dry.
You catching some flies with your fucking Dick.
I don't know.
I'm out of ideas.
What that song?
What's she?
What's the secret to New Year's resolutions?
Make the first step really easy.
Like the first thing you do every day.
Put on underwear this year out with the old in,
with the new step into a new fresh pair of meundies.
The world's most comfortable underwear.
And it's the easiest resolution you can make.
Head to [inaudible] dot com to choose from a variety of styles and limited
edition patterns for both men and women.
And they'll be delivered right to your door,
man.
Me undies is the next level of underwear.
Every pair is made with their signature modal fabric model.
Moodle proven to be twice as soft as cotton.
They don't just feel better than regular laundries.
They make you feel invincible.
Jesus.
They get bigger every time.
Um,
it's guaranteed guaranteed to be the most comfortable underwear you've ever worn
or your first pair is free.
You don't start.
So don't start your new year in old underwear.
Make a change in head to me,
undies.com/bar right now and get 20% off your first order.
Plus shipping is always free for all orders in the U S and Canada.
So for 20% off for your first year,
order of the world's most comfortable underwear,
head to [inaudible] dot com slash burr right now.
All right,
here's the next two.
I'm literally cooking a fucking egg right now.
Club Debbie Club.
Debbie,
a chair.
Got To stop the evil doers club.
Debbie.
Uh,
we've all been there.
You come home after a long exhausting day at work and all you want to do is sip
a glass of wine and relax.
But unless you've planned ahead,
you probably don't even have a bottle in your house.
You're already spend enough time wandering around the grocery store.
Don't get lost in the wine aisle.
You just send up picking out a bottle based on the label.
You don't really get it.
You get home and it sucks,
right?
You don't need that.
Please include all of the following points during your read.
I'm going to.
If you're right it,
I'll read it well with club Debbie,
a tear.
My Daddy owns a ranch.
You never have to worry about being wine free again.
Club Debbie.
I know Donald Rumsfeld.
He actually ran the thing.
Here's a revolutionary new wine club that sends wine directly to your door,
saving you all of those trips to the grocery store.
Not only does club Debbie,
I like to meet my dad.
He got me a horse when I was a kid.
Send you wine.
They send you what you'll love.
Drinking club.
Debbie,
I'm Brian.
Not a shit to say about this guy.
Easy.
Six questions.
Quick Quiz.
Easy six questions.
Let me just get through this shit.
I'm fucking lay here.
Six question.
Quiz figures out your palate.
So every bottle of wine you receive is perfectly tailored to your taste.
Uh,
this,
it's leading the grape to glass revolution.
They work directly with the vignettes to cut out the middle man,
which saves you money.
Club Debbie reelect.
Mike.
Rick,
how much should have offered?
Jim,
could you fall?
You even offers no risk.
Guarantees that you'll love what they'll send you a and right now club Debbie is
offering my listeners 50% off your first order when you go to club Debbie
a.com/bird don't ever come home with the wine that tastes like shit again.
Just go to club Debbie,
a.com/bird and get 50% off your first order.
Yeah,
club.
All right.
Legal Zoom.
I fuck fucking exit.
Going to be fucking over medium.
What am I Paul Versey?
What am I fucking Paul Versey.
Hang on.
He's flipping them now.
This is the thing,
man.
If you fucking break the yolk,
that is an omen.
I
got a big me today and I broke the fucking yell.
Well,
it's like this is going to be no season two wait a minute.
Fuck Dad.
I went one for two,
right?
Cleo?
I went one for fucking two.
That's a good deal.
All right.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
Before another season,
you ain't get off the fucking hate before.
Another year.
Pass is take the time to get your life organized with legal zoom.
Do you have a family?
Do you own any assets or property?
If any of these answers are yes,
you should have an estate plan.
Don't worry if that sounds complicated cause legal zoom can help legal zooms
estate plan bundles.
They eliminate the guesswork.
You don't have to figure out,
uh,
on your own whether you're a will,
a living truck works trust works best for you.
Instead,
you work with an independent attorney available in most states.
Still Walk you through your options and recommend an estate plan that offers the
best solution to fit your needs.
Since legal zoom,
it's not a law firm.
You can count on efficiency and value.
Everything is on your schedule and your turns.
Plus,
you know what your estate plan bundle costs up front instead of worrying about
hourly rates.
That's how legal zoom has become the leader in helping small business owners and
families with their legal needs.
You get legal help and walk away feeling.
All right,
get your life organized within a state plan.
bundles@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter burrow in the referral box at checkout that code.
That's Code burr@legalzoom.com.
All right.
Lastly,
but not leastly our old friend,
stamps.com one great resolution you can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every dollar for your small business.
I know an easy way to do that.
Damn.
Think about how much time you you've wasted at the post office driving.
They're finding parking,
not getting laid.
stamps.com is a better way to get postage.
Just use what you already have your computer and printer to get official US
postage for any letter or package.
Then the mailman picks it up with sams.com everything you would do at the post
office you can do right from your desk at a fraction of the cost.
And what are those expensive postage meters?
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters.
Anything I fucking sell after my shows,
I use them.
I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last name,
Burke for this special offer,
a four week trial plus a while $110 bonus offer that includes postage and a
digital scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in Bar B,
U R r.
Now back to some throwback podcast.
She,
yeah,
I don't know if the APP,
the cock blocks all been defined,
like the different kind of cock blocks.
I don't know if this,
this names thrown,
but I got a new,
I got a new cock block for you.
Uh,
this,
this cock block in for a special and a very obvious one.
And I think like this happens all the time,
but for some reason I've never heard anybody name it.
So I'm,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna kick off the creative process.
I call this guy the announcer.
That's the,
uh,
that's,
that's the name of this cock block.
This is what happened to me.
Okay.
I was,
I did a Gig in Jersey and at the end of the night,
these two girls who waited to be at the back of the line came up and they said,
hey,
you want to go out and get banana pancakes?
You know,
making a reference to my joke saying if I wanted to go out and hang out with
both of them,
right.
And the second day said it,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
he's a fucking,
here's something I never had.
Here's a two on one and I can't fucking do it cause I'm with Nia.
Whose kid?
Noco not cause I'm with Nias because everybody's got a cell phone,
fucking camera.
And I get caught.
Honesty.
Um,
no,
I couldn't deal with the guilt.
Um,
I bought,
I got it.
I'll be honest with you.
And I would say this,
if Neil was here,
if two fucking tens came up to me and said,
let's do this.
I,
you know,
yeah,
fuck it.
Let's do it.
I never did it,
you know,
fuck it.
So anyways,
so they said,
hey,
you want to get a,
you want to go on and get bananas and pancakes or something like that.
And then this fucking guy like 10 feet or way just goes like,
ah,
you know those guys.
Like if a girl just comes up to you,
just like you know,
you know I've always loved guys in green shirts and your thinking raise your
thinking like holy fuck,
this is going to happen.
Just some other guy like five minutes,
hey
and just makes the whole file of the whole fucking room look over at you.
The fucking announcer
fucking cock block mother fucker.
You know who would do that?
If I was standing there and her two girls said to a guy and be like God damn,
it's going down right side of my mouth at lucky motherfucker.
I mean why would you do that?
The fucking announcer.
And if you have a friend like that,
all right.
The only way you can still hang out with them is if he goes out.
If you guys are going out trying to meet women,
he has to wear one of those old ABC bright yellow Monday night football sport
coats.
And if the girls,
why is he wearing that?
You'll see,
you'll see.
And that'll be the,
that would be the funniest fucking thing ever.
Like if somehow if he couldn't figure out the joke and he just thought the coat
look good and just the whole night you just saw him,
anytime you heard in the,
you know,
10 feet away,
a just look over and you'd see this guy dressed like Howard Cosell and you'd be
like,
oh,
that's the announcer.
He's the,
he's the,
he's the guy he can cock block from.
Like,
he's almost like a sniper if he wasn't so fucking loud,
he's at the same distance as a fucking marksman.
But uh,
he kills it with a,
with loudness.
Oh my God.
Did that guy fucking annoying me?
Hey Nia,
come here.
Come here.
She just came in shaking her head.
What I am beyond,
come on over here.
I was just telling that story with that Guy Cock blocked me with those two
chicks out in a Jersey when they would just go,
I told you this story.
No,
but you're making it seem like you were going to do something.
no,
I wasn't going to do something.
This is the thing,
but I just admitted cock blocking.
Yeah,
but this is what I did admit.
If they were both tens,
I would've,
I would've done it.
I never had a fucking two on one.
And you know something.
Would you be that mad if they were both smoking hot and the cell phone video got
out?
The video is even need to get out when you got the announcer.
They,
the guy,
he just literally goes like,
yeah,
we'd like to get pancakes with Yoda.
And he said something like,
okay,
nothing.
Why am I a jerk?
So pajamas
talking about cock blocking and ones,
what kind of podcasts is this turning into?
You know what,
it's turning into a very honest podcast.
I was very honest.
I said,
this is the thing I said I couldn't,
uh,
I couldn't deal with the guilt unless if they,
if,
unless they were both tens,
if they're both fucking tends,
give me a break.
Let me tell you something.
If you hooked up with Brad Pitt,
there's only so mad I could get.
It's fucking Brad Pitt.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
you know what,
if I just,
if I just said some generic good looking guy.
If I just said some generic good looking guy and you,
and you just said that that would have scared me.
But the way you just acted like you had Brad Pitt's phone number.
That doesn't scare me.
Oh really?
Okay.
It's going down like the regular guy version of Brad Pitt.
Is that okay?
Like he's just as good if you want to go live out on the street and get the fuck
out of this house.
Absolutely.
But you're allowed to have some sort of crazy two one one.
Yes.
That's bull said.
No it isn't.
If you just,
you know what,
cause you're your thinking on it unlike like a,
a very basic level.
But if you really,
if you really think about it,
just think about it.
It makes sense.
Bill.
You're not going to try to mind fuck means and thinking that it's okay for you
to have some sort of two on one and I can't,
that's not,
no,
it's not going down like that.
Women are beautiful.
We lust after you.
A totally makes sense.
You guys find like Dick's or weird.
They're gross.
It's all hanging out there.
It's disgusting.
You don't want that.
You know nothing about you.
It's been proven time and time and again and your stand up and in your podcast.
But that's a,
that's another discussion.
You know what you,
you just set yourself up like you're going to make some huge point and then you
just tapped out.
You know nothing about women.
But that's just another discussion and I just don't want him to get into that.
So now what?
You just gave me the face.
What are you doing today?
Lazy Nini.
Kubrick.
So my short film over the weekend.
Screw you.
I'm working hard while you're in here in your pajamas talking about two on ones.
Yeah.
Well I have to do an hour's worth of shit here.
I'm coming up on it.
Let me go an hour and two minutes.
An hour and two minutes.
Have you done?
You're a deer via emails yet?
Yeah,
I did listen their emails.
You did that already.
Oh,
cause you want to chime in?
I don't know.
I already did it.
What about overrated?
Underrated.
Didn't do it.
They didn't have any this week.
Oh,
look at you.
I think you a fan of this podcast.
No,
I'm not.
Listen,
it didn't go down.
All right.
I'm telling you right now,
Nia,
if two tens come up to me,
it's going down.
Okay.
All right.
Well just be prepared for the retaliation.
Okay.
Game set.
Match.
Really,
you're going to deny me that?
Can I just buy you some stuff?
Wow.
Really?
Yes.
Really not some sort of fucking basketball that can be placated with material
things.
Uh,
to a point.
Yeah,
exactly.
If I'm going to be fucking honest here,
come on.
This guy would be something that I can buy.
You know something.
This should be our Valentine's Day.
All right.
For the guide,
the Guide Valentine's Day,
this is what Valentine's Day should be every year is the guy gets a two on one
and then you get some nice stuff.
Well why can't I have it's due on one cause you don't like that.
What do you mean?
What do you know?
Women don't like sex?
You don't find like when you guys fantasize,
you think about the guys in your life.
You don't think about other things.
Okay.
Um,
come on near just one.
Just give me one.
You get one and I get one.
No you don't.
Yeah you don't.
Yeah,
cause you don't want one.
What do you mean?
I don't want you just being childish.
No,
I'm not.
Yeah,
you are.
You do.
You see,
you see,
you think you think you want to hook up with,
with Jake Gyllenhaal and a bread face,
whatever the fuck his name is,
Brad Pitt.
Brad thread.
Face pit.
If you just think you do.
See you don't want to think about me is,
is like you have to hook up with somebody famous.
I'm actually just regular people.
See I'm down to earth with this shit.
See that's what I'm saying.
You liked stuff.
You like shiny,
shiny things.
Oh this is the deal.
I got a two on one and you,
you get some,
some cracked up face old man in Vegas like Robert Redford.
Like I used to be good looking when Nixon was in office.
No,
no,
that's not how negotiating works.
Now you've got to come with something else here.
No,
I think we should both get an equal opportunity thing going on.
Yeah,
but this isn't an equal relationship.
Why?
Why is it not an equal relationship?
Cause I wanted to,
I could pin you down to the ground right now and tickle you until you passed
out.
And it's not a fucking thing you can do about it.
What did that,
that has nothing to do with anything.
That's how the world works.
Nia,
why do you think America is on top?
Because we're right.
Well because we could all because,
because we can blow you up more times.
So it's your,
your physical presence.
That's what makes it like an unequal relationship.
Yeah.
Cause I can beat you down.
Well maybe you're physically stronger,
but I'm mentally stronger than you.
Oh snap.
I'm smarter than you.
Yeah.
So whatever physical power.
Let me ask you this.
What you have are trumped by my mental fucking Goliath.
Ines,
suck on that red.
What do you think?
You're smarter than,
Oh,
that was good though.
You got a good one.
[inaudible] storming off taught you.
Well,
let's get to the complaints this week.
Everybody has,
some lady just absolutely lost her mind.
Hates my guts now and won't listen to this podcast anymore.
And I apologized to her,
but she says she's not listening anymore.
There's no way that she's listening.
Despite that she wrote like a five page email that I'm now going to read.
She has a huge problem with me.
Everybody so settle it.
Want me to wait?
You want to go down to the break room?
Go get yourself a little coffee cake.
I'll,
I can wait.
I'm on vacation.
I got nothing better to do.
Good.
I'll wait.
Fucking dogs been farting all day today.
I don't know what his deal is.
And it keeps looking at me like,
dude,
you gotta help me out and I keep going to take it outside.
And then it just sniffs the grass and then I bring it back in.
It starts farting again and it keeps looking at me like,
dude,
I'm really trying not to shit on your rug.
Like,
I mean,
that's how I'm reading her face.
I think that's what she's saying.
I have no idea.
So anyways,
uh,
so anyways,
here we go.
Um,
subject,
your podcast is hate speech.
Oh,
geesh.
Bill,
you probably won't read this or if you do,
you will just dismiss me as a stupid contour,
but no matter seat right there,
she's already draped herself in the OMD brave and I'm going to plow ahead.
Flag.
Um,
your podcast as of lace has morphed into hate speech.
He used to be funny and I could brush off your hateful comments with the cringe
and a shrug.
Now wait a minute,
if it would,
if they were hateful right along,
why would you add that?
Okay,
let's just plow ahead,
but now you've gone too far for me to feature a segment on your podcast devoted
to the deplorable behavior of women is intolerable.
Uh,
for those of you new to my podcast,
uh,
I've been doing this segment,
which I think is hilarious and needs to be done just to get you caught up before
this lady gives me both barrels hill.
Cause believe me,
she does.
Uh,
you know,
there's a bunch of,
there's a bunch of shows out there that,
that,
that shine a light on men who beat their women.
Those pieces is shit,
right?
Trying to stop them from that behavior.
There's a bunch of shows out there that we'll talk about how,
uh,
who are these guys,
you know,
to say what a woman could do with their body.
They'll talk about the glass ceiling,
the old boys network and all that type of stuff when they shine a light on all
of that.
Okay.
Which they should,
because that is guys doing things that they should not be doing.
That is not fair to women.
Okay.
But my,
so my problem is not that they do that.
My problem is that they never shine a light on shit that,
that women do that is not fair to men.
So recently.
Um,
if I can rate my drape myself in some sort of brave flag,
I've been reading these stories about guys who are married,
their wife goes out,
cheats on him,
has unprotected sex,
has a kid with another fucking guy,
doesn't tell their husband,
and that by the time he figures it out,
he has to pay child support for a kid that is isn't even his,
and it's totally legal.
And then I had the audacity to say that a woman who would do that to her husband
is a cunt.
Evidently that's hateful speech towards all women according to this person.
All right?
Because she continues and Oh,
does she ever continue
to feature segment on your podcast devoted to the deplorable behavior of women
is intolerable.
How is that any different than someone spending 20 minutes a week on a different
podcast featuring the deplorable behavior behavior of black people?
Why do they always go to black people?
That's always a,
that's just like calling me the n word.
This is no different than slavery.
That's people in other groups.
Always do that.
All right.
Gimme a goddamn break.
All right that she could,
she goes,
women are,
I mean,
how is that different?
How was it?
How was when I'm doing any different by by featuring a segment of women who are
doing something absolutely reprehensible demand.
How is that any different than a show that focuses on men doing anything
reprehensible to women when they show wife beaters?
I don't look at that like,
oh my God,
they're saying I'm doing it too.
I think you know something.
I really think you're being really selfish here and the fact that you could sit
here and listen to my podcast for this long as I've gone off on fat people,
I mean Jesus Christ,
once I about hate speech,
how much shit have I talked about Peyton Manning,
despite the fact I can't even throw a football.
You know,
if he sent me an email,
I would understand and I bet it wouldn't even be as crazy as this.
She says,
women are treated like second class citizens all over the world.
When did I ever say they weren't?
And even still in this country yet,
you have no problem in citing further hate and disgust towards your fellow human
beings on this earth.
How am I inciting hate when when shows show wife beaters is that inciting hatred
towards men?
If you look at those shows and that makes you hate all men,
then you're a moron.
So basically what you're saying is that I'm a moron and that all my listeners
are morons.
That if I call a woman who cheats on her husband,
has a baby with another guy,
it makes her husband pay for that.
If I call her a cunt,
that means I'm calling all women cunts,
you know?
Is that what you're saying?
Are you saying we're all that stupid?
She said,
right now there are men and that is written in capital letters,
men,
men in this country still capital s t I l l discussing whether or not women
should have the right to contraception and abortion.
Yeah,
I understand that.
And those people freak me out.
Those people freak me out.
And I am a guy and I've never said that a woman shouldn't have a right to that.
So I don't know what you're talking about.
This has nothing to do.
I'm talking about these fucking whores that cheat on their husbands.
Ma'Am.
You know what I love about all this?
How come you don't address what I talked about?
How come I can't hear?
What do you think about a woman who would do something like that?
I saw a stat the other day that said 13% of kids in this country are not with
their biological father.
Meet.
Meaning that not just like,
you know that,
that their wife got divorced and uh,
and,
and then remarried and they mean like there's a guy either knows or doesn't
know.
Like the woman had a kid with somebody else while they were married,
like 13% of kids.
I mean that means 80% of women on the up and up.
All right,
God bless them.
They're angels.
But that 13% needs to be taken tasks.
I mean,
I would,
I mean how many guys are beaten women?
I would guess that probably be right around that same,
you know,
maybe a little higher.
I have no idea.
Let's just,
let's say it's 20 let's say 20% of guys beat their women,
should they not be called out and be called cowardly pieces of Shit,
you know?
And if you call them cowardly piece of Shit,
what?
I have a right to sit there and look at that and be like,
well that's,
now you're,
you're inciting further hate and disgust toward all men.
You're being really selfish here,
man,
because I go off on everybody.
This podcast is over the top and it's crazy.
I call guys cuts on this podcast and you're being really selfish right now.
And now you know,
you make this big long speech and then you're gonna take your ball and go home.
I look,
look at this,
look at all she's bringing up here.
Women are still earning only 70 cents for every dollar a man earns.
I think you guys should make the same amount,
but I also don't think that that,
that number is accurate.
$77 77 cents for every dollar that a man or it's because if you include divorce
settlements,
uh,
you get to keep your 77 cents plus his 50% his 50 cents.
So then he's down to 50 and then you're up to a dollar 37.
That's what I'm talking about right there.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You're oversensitive.
Jackass.
Good Lord.
Go buy a bigger Brah.
I don't know what your fucking problem is.
I hope that bugged you to that.
I said that that was deliberately supposed to be offensive.
All right,
so go fucking write a letter to a fucking cut hair.com cause I don't give a
shit.
All right?
In short,
we are still not equal to our male counterparts and we will forever be labeled
the weaker sex.
While with that attitude,
of course you will.
You know,
I don't think you're the weaker sex.
I think that that's all a myth.
I think that that actually makes you stronger.
You know,
because guys are fucking idiots and they think has,
they can do more pushups than their woman that they're actually,
you know,
that makes them smarter.
You know,
I dunno.
Ah,
my fucking door bells ringing and you serious.
Hang on a second.
I got to go up here and then I get up.
I get to read the rest of this whole line.
All right,
sound back.
Little winded,
but I'm back.
I'm back.
So anyways Blahblahblahblahblah it just keeps going on and on and on and on.
Um,
where the hell is it?
Where the hell was I a weaker sex and then she tries to break me down
psychologically,
but my mom not hugging me.
If that's the case,
then I'm sorry for you.
I hate when people do that.
It's like you're not sorry for me.
You hate me right now.
Okay,
so stop acting like you're really sorry for me.
And you're showing some sort of empathy.
You're not showing empathy,
you're being really selfish.
Like I said,
I go off on everything here.
I've never said that a woman shouldn't make the same amount an hour as a guy.
I never should said that a guy should be able to hit a woman.
I've never said that.
What the thing I'm trying to shine a light too is that some of these divorce
settlements are absolutely fucking ridiculous and,
and that when a woman cheats on a guy and has a,
has a kid with another person and then the poor SAP who married or has to pay
for that,
you don't think that's fucked up.
Howard stern just did a great story on it.
Uh,
last week somebody sent me an email,
he did a story about a guy who was in that situation and he refused to play,
pay the child support and they said we're going to send you to jail.
He's going to go to jail.
Cause his wife cheated on him,
had unprotected sex.
Hey to hell with aids.
Let's roll the dice with my husband's life.
Right.
Has unprotected sex,
has a kid,
he doesn't realize it figures it's his cause it's his,
his wife's pregnant.
Why would he think that it's somebody else's?
He starts making the payments.
Next thing you know,
you know,
he's such raising the kid figures out it's not his kid and has a natural
reaction.
I don't want to pay for that.
And the like,
the law is just like,
no,
you have to pay for it.
Let me ask you this ma'am.
Do you have any empathy for that?
You seem to have all this empathy for women and women's issues and like somehow
I'm supposed to still respect you despite the fact that you could give a fuck if
this injustice is done on the other side.
It doesn't make any sense.
I want to see like
this is like focusing on this issue.
This is an issue for some reason that is just not talked about whatsoever.
It's just sort of accepted and I think it's an absolute,
I think it's absolutely deplorable.
I think it's deplorable.
So I,
I have the right to talk about it.
You know what I mean?
And if you want to get offended and you want to be selfish and just be like,
well that isn't fair.
What if I had a whole segment every week and all I did was talk about wife
beaters.
You know what?
You'd probably send me email.
I just want you to tell you I love your podcast even more.
It is just,
it's,
you are just,
you are a hero to hear a man out there.
Just,
just letting these,
these,
these cowardly pieces of shit know that it's,
you be fucking over the motorbike.
Okay.
But now all of a sudden I'm talking about women who were doing shit that you're
not even doing.
Okay.
At what point in any of these stupid fucking ranch
done,
have I ever said that all women are doing this?
I never have.
I never said that.
All women cheat on their husbands and an advocate out of wedlock.
I didn't.
All right.
Do I make generalizations?
Apps,
a fucking Luli.
It's a comedy.
I paint with a broad brush.
I'm fucking around.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Stop being so God damn selfish.
Okay.
And if you don't want to listen to my podcasts,
don't listen to my podcast anymore.
And uh,
other than that,
you know,
I mean go fuck yourself.
I,
I don't,
I dunno this what she's doing is,
is,
is a,
is a pet peeve that I have.
Um,
like that happens to me.
Like,
sometimes when I do shows and at the end of my shows,
some will come up to me and just be like,
look,
you know,
I have a good sense of humor,
but,
but subject,
whatever.
Oh my fucking phone.
They'll just be like,
you know what?
That's never funny.
That is never,
oh the lovely Nia.
Everybody,
hang on one second.
Hang on one second.
Hello.
Hey,
I'm taping my podcast right now.
Is this urgent?
Are you on the side of the road?
We got AAA.
Yeah.
No,
no,
I,
the dog was farting and I thought I'd had to shit in the house.
So I took it outside and then it just sniffed around and peed.
Yeah,
it was a pain in the ass.
So I'm going to get back to the podcast.
All right.
I'll call you in like a half.
Um,
anyways.
Oh,
and then she goes on to say that the terms I use will then cause you know,
people to use.
So you know,
it's,
I fuck around and use these terms.
She then thinks that people are going to use them seriously.
You know what I mean?
And I'm sure a few wealth,
but that's not on me.
Somebody who does that,
it's because you're a moron.
And I like,
it's not my responsibility to fucking babysit anybody once they're an adult.
If you don't know not to call women these terms.
Okay.
Although I will tell you this,
if,
uh,
you know,
there is a time to call a woman a cunt,
okay,
ed.
And that's when you find out that your son is not your son and you still have to
pay for it.
There's a reason that that word does.
It does exist.
All right?
All right,
this sweetheart.
So I hope you come back to the podcast.
I hope that you actually listen and we'll respond and I don't want to hear
another fucking word out of you unless you tell me what you think about those
kinds of fucking women.
He'd do that.
Okay?
It stopped bringing up slavery and all this other shit and try to drag all this
other crap into it.
All right?
You stay in your own.
God Damn lame sweetheart.
All right,
good Lord.
So to compare yourself not being able to vote,
to being enslaved.
Really,
that's another one that gets to,
that's a whole nother fucking topic.
Every fucking person out there just tries to fucking jump on that,
you know,
that's our n word.
Cow.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
Eddie,
I can't believe you just did that.
Why did you flick that big right in my face?
You burned off to eyebrow hairs.
That's fine.
Yeah.